Mais surtout, puisqu'on est dans 1 monde médiatique,
la chose qui est la plus frappante,
que t'on habite depuis 7 ans
dans la ruralité profonde,
c'est le fait que les gens de là-bas,
les gens d'ici, pour moi, quand j'y suis,
euh, ce sont des gens
dont la vision est toujours en stéréo,
pour 1 simple raison,
ils ont d'un côté le monde qu'ils ont sous leurs yeux,
dont je parle en partie dans le livre,
et ils ont le monde qu'il voit sur les écrans
ou qui leur vient par les médias
et qui est 1 monde assez surréaliste,
parce que rien n'est plus étonnant comme expérience
que, euh. De regarder la télévision,
d'écouter la radio quand on est dans, euh,
cette ruralité profonde